Toronto landlord tries to rent out three
individual beds in the same room for
four hundred and twenty dollars each
this guy tries to run a dormitory
I don't know what this is this looks
like
this looks like prison bro this this
disease
it's crazy for 422 dollars bugging
utilities and Wi-Fi included separate
entrance you can't have a separate
entrance to the well for all three of
you I guess that makes me think of all
the like
the flight attendants that were in
Vancouver the post was deleted Sunday
evening shortly after it was posted
yeah because it's crazy
people said they weren't going to attack
the house because they were so upset at
the list
I and I get it you know what I believe I
get it I believe it you wanna know why I
believe Toronto's crazy yeah I believe
it some people would get there show up
and be like ah this is a blood clot
house yo run this and they would
they would I 100 the the ad itself is
illegal because Jerry's based on the
speech you can't listen at for that many
people living in the same room so that's
illegal so I didn't know that already
uh man why am I bringing this up because
rent is crazy right now yeah it's been
getting crazy for the last couple years
and some places been crazy for the last
decade all right but if you don't live
in some of these shitty ass places you
guys notice like well that's three four
years this shit's shot through the roof
and you know we've talked about this
Montreal always been way more affordable
than other places yeah out of the three
main cities North America in general
it's just crazy how much more I tell
people what I pay for my apartment yeah
the dream I'm like yeah 1100 for a three
bedroom apartment downtown big big rooms
big rooms backyard everything downtown
close to Metro no crazy crime nothing
1100.
they're paying that much for a bedroom
in some places you know what I'm saying
a rent
and [ __ ] is so crazy that's why these
people were mad of course they're like
prop trying to find a place and you want
to insult my eyes with this [ __ ]
three bedrooms in a prison-like city
yeah how are you supposed to live there
yeah how did people be mad I want to
burn people's place but I I can
understand the sentence the
[ __ ] can show up at this place
oh you think you gonna rent this out now
when I'm done mother they were gonna go
crazy they would a hundred percent go
and pardon me after looking at those
beds would be like [ __ ] your house
reserves to burn those beds were
disgusting yeah what do you think about
the rent situation well people took
opportunities and raise the prices
people try to make more more money Greek
agreed you know I mean
it's a bit crazy even here like there's
a there's we still have a sort of a
crisis it's not as bad as everybody else
or everywhere else with the prices but
we still have a crisis where we don't
have enough housing for people yeah you
understand so it's yeah it's crazy but
with this whole covet situation that
happened
people realize that they don't have to
work so close to home to well so close
to a center of the city they can go well
there's a lot of things that can be done
outside the city Montreal was really
different than other cities that I've uh
that I've uh encountered because when
you want to go out in Montreal you go
downtown when you go la you don't really
go downtown right when you go to New
York you go downtown but the real
parties are like in the hoods every in
The Burbs
um Miami it's not downtown downtown it's
not like where the center a city is it's
like South Beach was another thing so in
other cities
it's not the downtown area even like in
Calgary it's not downtown that you're
gonna do the most things are that's for
the business you understand I know what
I'm saying so Montreal is going to start
to be like that downtown downtown is
maybe gonna die out for the suburbs
there's gonna be new centers that are
going to start no but there's already
new centers look at the South Shore they
have their centers look at the uh North
Shore they have their centers out west
they have their centers it started it
started you know what I mean because of
that because of well mainly because of
the housing so uh it's it's gonna be
it's really hard to predict because you
know it's human beings and stuff like
that but yeah I do think that there's
something to be done there yeah and it
would be good not to replicate what
other cities are doing yeah but for me I
think affordable rent when I first moved
here seven years ago such a big deal
because you know I'm trying to figure
out my way as a you know on the YouTube
and stand up space and yeah you know
when you're paying 420 for your own room
every it's all included yeah you know
you have a lot more money and flexible
money to do into other things right if
you're working part-time you can pay
your bills and still have a life you can
go enjoy art events you go to museums
you go on dates you can go to friends
with restaurants and not have to work
such crazy hours just to pay your bills
and save money so there's the
flexibility for me in terms of you know
creating a startup and then doing my own
thing because of the fact that I didn't
have so much of my money going into my
bills and then it also gave me a much
better quality of life because I wasn't
working so much just to be able to enjoy
a tiny bit of freedom I actually had a
lot more flexibility in that regard so I
think one thing that I realized from
moving from Los Angeles to moving to
Montreal is like how much of a burden is
lifted off your shoulders when you get
to live in an environment where rent is
accessible in places that matter yeah I
didn't have to move two hours away from
the city or anything like that I could
be here you could be really have access
to everything to be part of like a
cultural fabric yeah and to live like a
good quality of life where I got my
personal time my work time and uh then
you got to buy a car then you got the
bills yeah you you can live away but
then it gives more it gives you more
expenses not only that not only to give
you more expensive it gives you less
incentive because the further something
is a way to less like you are to go yeah
I could go to a cultural event because
it's 20 minutes by Walker bus if I gotta
drive 40 minutes it's a different thing
I got to put a lot more labor into it
then I gotta find parking deal with
traffic deal with that stress right
you know like and you always got to
check the time because you got to go
home because you got you know stuff like
that I remember reading the study that
said that happiness levels for employees
were limited how long their commute was
to work I can understand the longer the
commute the more likely the Depression
was for the people when I talked to
people in New York and they tell me that
they have to commute like
an hour and a half nah we're not doing
that you know I mean oh I work I work in
Manhattan okay cool where'd you live so
baton what yeah what you were you
where'd you live where'd you work
Manhattan where you live Far Rockaway
and what do you do bus and Metro I'm
like but they don't have a choice they
can't drive they can't drive but that's
that's
extensive think about what an hour and a
half is let's say you're doing it both
ways because some people do it both ways
but let's be generous let's say it's an
hour there an hour back that's two hours
you might have about
16 to 14 hours that you're awake you got
two hours of driving eight hours of work
that's 10 hours spent right there that
means you may have four to six hours at
most
if it's an hour and a half it goes fast
if it's an hour and a half it's 11 hours
so it's so eight hours so your day is
done that's if you don't want it your
day is done that's if you don't want to
do overtime let's say [ __ ]
because you have to pay your rent you
want to do overtime so now you do two or
three hours overtime but we're at 15
hours a day you bet you're out rough and
you gotta sleep in that in bus drives
and all that stuff involves so much
[ __ ] it's like bro no there's so
much [ __ ] especially New York oh
yeah [ __ ] say that again [ __ ]
stupid it is it is it is so
like I just can't I want to relate to
you guys like just for me living the
students and then moving here like how
much of a difference it made in my
quality of life I cannot tell you I can
understand I didn't understand it until
I lived it and I'm like this is living
this is a life
I do things
and I do them when I want how I want and
you're not so stressed bruh and I'm not
I need is not making money like that but
now it's not making money like that I
was a struggling artist but I had an
opportunity to live in so I think that's
the beauty of what I had to experience
here knowing that it's disappearing
makes me sad and knowing that it's not
accessible to most people in most places
makes me sad but I do want folks to know
that that's not the only way to live
you're not supposed to be stressing
about your bills every but most folks
live paycheck to pay for yourself it's
one of those things that made me say in
this ad
was uh was the evidence of that so just
wanted to share that with you guys
anything you want to add about this let
us know what you guys think in the
comments below we want to hear from you